The Joe Rogan Experience what it's been
the reaction like what has been the most
uh visceral or violent reaction to What
You've uh you've done and exposed
I think the biggest story we probably
ever broke in was either the FTX stuff
that was already kind of going on it's
probably the Logan Paul story The crypto
Zoo Saga
um that was a case where you know it's
just the Classic influencer greed story
where this guy launches
an nft project does millions upons
millions of dollars in sales and
delivers nothing he promises the world a
fun blockchain game that earns you money
and he he did nothing and the project
was left abandoned and people were like
miserable complaining complaining no one
says it but I'm not aware of the voice
I'm kind of aware that you covered it
but I don't know the story
so let me let me back up then so okay
uh Logan Paul is popular influencer you
know who yeah sure
um so he along with a lot of influencers
got really interested in like the crypto
space and he had done a coin before that
called dink doink
which was abandoned shortly after he
promoted it people got invested goes to
zero right and he says well that's not
my project that was my buddy's project
and then like a month later he's like I
actually do have a project excited to
announce it it's called cryptozoo it's a
fun game they called it a fun game that
earns you money basically the idea is
they're going to sell you these two
things eggs is nft and then there's a
coin aspect to it called Zoo tokens okay
so you can buy these Zoo tokens to buy
the eggs and the idea is the eggs will
then hatch into animals that will earn
passive Zoo tokens
so you're you can buy eggs with Zoo
tokens and then the eggs will passively
earn Yuzu tokens does that make sense no
well don't worry you're you're kind of
actually caught up uh so these Zoo
tokens were basically this passive
income you know you basically invest up
front and then you're sort of getting
the tokens back out which you can sell I
guess
so
that was the idea pitched to people and
people immediately Buy in they three
million dollars in nft sales
tens of millions of dollars in the
tokens itself the zoo tokens people are
so excited about it because it's Logan
Paul and he says this is his project
he's putting his name behind it his back
behind it and he's a great marketer I
mean you got to give the guy credit
where credit is due he's a tremendous
marketer so people get all excited
all of a sudden the the hatch day comes
when you're supposed to hatch these eggs
and half the hatching doesn't work
how does the hatching work is it on a
computer model it was on what is it it
was on the blockchain so you could like
you your nfts would turn into different
nfts like they would like they would
transform into the animals they go from
an egg to an animal how
uh it's just blockchain coding I mean
it's just it's just but how do they is
it is it predetermined yeah yeah how
does your egg become it's just true it's
just random it's like it's supposed to
be randomly generated uh animals so you
and so you might get a rhino you might
get yeah and chicken exactly and then
you could like crossbreed your rhino
with like a chicken and get like a A
ricken or something and get even more
tokens but uh is this it yeah there it
is you get like bear shark so like Panda
so people start to like is this still
around
so they say they're gonna go back and
fix it now so Logan after being not
involved for like a year
as soon as my video comes out he goes
damn what a coincidence like I've been
working on it like I was gonna you know
make it like launch it in reality he
hadn't touched it for a very long period
of time but so so sorry to back up okay
the uh half the token half the eggs
don't work and they're not actually
earning anything the whole time they
said they're gonna earn you these tokens
right they're not earning anything
so the promises haven't been fulfilled
there's just sort of all this stuff
going on behind and behind the scenes
Logan's quiet come to find out he had
hired basically criminals who were
selling on the back end like some of the
tokens
and he was sort of like I I don't know
what his his thing was I think he
realized like oh it's not gonna be that
successful let me move on I think his
mentality was let me just move on right
the problem though is you have millions
of dollars of investment in a thing that
you promoted you told everyone it was
going to make the money and then you
never delivered anything so my story was
basically
showing that showing the victims of the
scheme and then response he's like well
I'm gonna sue you for that he said he's
gonna see you yeah he said I'll see you
in court
and then the backlash against him was so
severe that he releases a video saying
thank you coffeezilla for showing at the
world what happened and I appreciate it
I responded out of anger but I'm gonna
make things right I'm gonna fix the game
to what it was supposed to be and I'm
gonna pay back
1.7 million dollars I'm committing 1.7
million to anyone who bought an nft can
get a refund now there's a bit of an
issue with that so that's nice I
actually think it's great that that
happened but uh there's two issues with
it number one which is that
the nfts were only half a small part of
the sales they actually weren't even
half they because people bought these
tokens so the people who bought tokens
get nothing he's offering you know this
refund on the the nfts the other problem
is he hasn't refunded the nfts I've been
I've actually reached out to him twice
uh it's been like over a month since
he's done this so he said he's going to
do it and then the Discord like he's
posting in this little chat room with
the investors
after he said he was going to do it he's
posted nothing there's no way to get a
refund right now so I keep asking him
like Hey where's you promised 1.7
million to these investors they're all
waiting it's been over uh I think it's
almost been two months now and there's
nothing so it's like you know he says
that he's refunding people which sounds
great for PR and then it's just like
radio silence so
what I'm ultimately looking for is some
accountability from these guys they're
happy to make money from the Endeavors
they're happy to potentially make
millions of dollars from these you know
different projects they're spinning up
but the second accountability is asked
for
you can't reach them so is it well I
would assume Logan's a very busy guy and
sure I would assume that he probably
didn't come up with this on his own I
would assume that someone probably came
to him with this project this is just
total assumption guesswork guessing on
my part so we have text messages for
behind the scenes a lot of people's the
people who are responsible for say Logan
kind of spearheaded the idea and he says
he's spearheaded the idea so it was his
idea yeah
and and so he's working with someone
right that probably assured him that
this would work
uh yeah I mean he had a he had this team
of a few guys who
they didn't do much vetting into and
some of them turned out to be criminals
but you know my my feeling is ultimately
no matter what happens like when you
take people's money that's what I'm
trying to like on my show I'm trying to
tell these like influencers like when
you take people's money it's different
when you tell them you're gonna make
them money and you get into the
financial investment game your
responsibility is different you can't
just always pass the buck to like uh it
was like a guy that's not that
trustworthy it's like all right that
might be true then go fix it Go hire
some more guys that are trustworthy and
fix the thing and I think
um my experience because I've talked to
Logan and that's why I know he didn't
respond to me because I I texted him I
said Hey where's this money he left me
on red but I've talked to him and when I
talk to him you know
there's just sort of this feeling of
he's like I just don't want to think
about this like I don't want to be you
know he wants to focus on Prime which is
successful he doesn't want to be
bothered with the victims of the scheme
that he ultimately thought of in the
first place
so it's still is it possible that he's
just Gathering the money or working out
a way to do it legally where it it makes
sense it's it's very frustrating because
you know at at every turn it's just sort
of like uh you know it is I want to say
it's possible we just don't know and
it's just sort of like
when you promise people re refunds like
the longer you wait you know the less
people are actually going to take that
refund if Walmart says hey bring in
bring in this skull I'll give you a
refund and you're like all right when
can I bring it in and then I'll respond
to you for two months
they know that you're less likely to
actually take the refund
so I don't know if he's doing it because
he wants less people to get the refund
he probably is busy but my thought is
a transgression of this magnitude where
you're playing with people's money and
livelihoods you cannot take it lightly
and that's one of the things is these
influencers got into this crypto space I
don't think they fully appreciated
they're now dealing with financial
investments and it's not a joke it's not
like a brand deal where you know if uh
nordvpn isn't as great as they said it
was you know it's all cool right it's
now it's your company and you promise
people you're gonna make the money and
now you haven't said anything for over a
year then you say you're going to refund
them and you don't say anything for two
months that's a that's an issue